A D-Class drag-races through the testing zone,
screaming at the top of his lungs and doing
donuts.
A mime who is also in the testing chamber
stares with disapproval, tapping his foot
impatiently.
Did we mention that the car is made of spiders?
Yeah, this is gonna be a weird one, folks.
Stay tuned for one of the craziest SCP stories
you’ve ever heard…
Emily had always dreamed of taking a trip
to Paris.
When the opportunity actually came to visit
the city, she was overjoyed.
She spent her time exploring art museums,
tasting the bread and cheese, and walking
through the city streets, taking in the sights.
One of her favorite things about Paris was
all of the street performers.
As she walked, nibbling on a pain au chocolat,
she delighted in the antics of jugglers, tossing
colorful balls into the air.
She gasped at the feats of athleticism and
grace demonstrated by acrobats and contortionists.
She giggled at the absurd shows put on by
puppeteers, and dabbed tears from her eyes
at the sound of beautiful songs played and
sung by musicians.
It became part of her daily routine.
One night, as Emily was walking back to her
hostel after a long, languid dinner, she found
herself walking down a street she had not
encountered before.
There was no one around except for her.
It was a lovely moment of peace, but it also
struck her as a little bit eerie, and she
wished for the familiar throngs of people.
Up ahead, she spotted the silhouette of another
person, and let out a sigh of relief.
As she got closer, she could make out the
black and white striped shirt, the suspenders,
the black beret, the white face makeup, rouged
cheeks, and red lips.
A mime!
A real, classic French mime!
She couldn't believe her luck.
When he spotted Emily approaching, the mime
began to start a performance.
He began with a classic: the invisible box.
He felt around the walls of the invisible
box, looking out with exaggerated wide eyes
and an open mouth.
Emily clapped, and reached into her bag for
a little bit of money she could use to tip
him.
After all, he was putting on a performance
just for her.
He deserved it!
She walked closer to the mime, looking for
a place to put her tip.
She didn't see one, so she held up her hand,
offering the money directly to the mime.
As he took notice of how close she was getting,
the mime began shaking his head vigorously,
eyes wide and insistent.
She didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her, until it was too late.
Dozens and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face, out from inside of his
clothes, from his shoes, pouring over the
street and crawling up onto Emily.
She tried to brush them off, she tried to
run away, but no matter how hard she tried,
the spiders just kept coming.
All she could do was scream.
In an attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance, Emily unwittingly came across
SCP-3247.
SCP-3247 is a humanoid entity standing at
approximately 1.7 meters in height.
It wears a striped shirt and suspenders similar
to the garb of a stereotypical French mime,
as well as what appears to be white makeup
on its face and all other exposed skin.
Though these aspects of its appearance seem
as if they should be removable, the clothing
and makeup are, in fact, parts of the entity's
physiology, and cannot be removed from its
body.
This is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form.
Though it looks corporeal and solid, the entity
cannot touch or directly interact with any
solid matter, with one particular exception.
There is a colony of spiders living on and
inside of SCP-3247.
These spiders have been officially designated
SCP-3247-A, and are highly protective of SCP-3247.
If anyone or anything attempts to approach
SCP-3247 in a threatening manner, the spiders
will swarm the potential threat.
As any savvy anomalous activity enthusiast
might have already gathered, these are, of
course, no ordinary spiders.
Not only do they dwell on and in an intangible
mime, but they have a peculiar response to
witnessing a human being making specific gestures
or pantomiming activities.
When this occurs, the colony of spiders will
form the shape of an object related to the
gestures, which they will then hold for up
to three hours, or until given additional
stimuli that prompt a change in shape.
While the spider colony is assembled into
a shape, they will be able to share some of
the given objects' functions in spite of being
technically nothing more than a mass of well-coordinated
arachnids.
As for SCP-3247, it is either incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak.
Instead, it communicates with Foundation staff
via silent miming.
When it does, the spiders will frequently
react to its gestures, becoming, effectively,
living props.
SCP-3247 does not seem to be especially thrilled
with this, likely because miming is inherently
a propless art form, and these spider-based
props undermine its artistic vision.
Otherwise, though, the presence of the spiders
does not seem to bother SCP-3247.
In order to better understand the nature of
SCP-3247-A, Foundation Staff conducted a series
of tests.
In each test, a D-Class was given a gesture
to perform in the presence of SCP-3247.
Then, the research staff would record the
spider colony's response.
During the first test, the research staff
ordered D-11424 to attempt to get as close
to SCP-3247 as possible.
They did not, of course, warn him about the
spiders.
He entered the testing chamber and approached
the mime, who was pantomiming the act of climbing
stairs.
As the mime pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase, and D-11424 grew closer, instances
of SCP-3247-A emerged to take on the shape
of a staircase, much to the mime's frustration.
SCP-3247 stopped its performance, throwing
up its hands in a gesture of defeat.
The spiders turned their attention to D-11424,
and began to swarm him, treating him as a
potential threat.
Panicking, and unsure how to communicate with
SCP-3247 while the spiders were overpowering
him, D-11424 began to wave frantically at
the mime.
The mime simply shrugged, giving him a look
that said "Well, what do you want me to do
about it?"
At this point, Control intervened, instructing
D-11424 to pantomime some kind of activity.
Fortunately, before turning to a life of crime,
D-11424 had spent several years in a professional
improv troupe, and was well-acquainted with
pantomime.
His performing instincts kicked in, and he
leaped into action.
He put a hand to his ear, as if listening
to the ringing of a telephone.
The spiders stopped their attack, responding
immediately to his cue.
They formed into the shape of a small table,
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on top.
The mime rolled its eyes in disdain at the
sight of this prop-based performance, but
D-11424 was on a roll.
He crossed to the phone, picked up the receiver,
and held it to his ear.
"Hello?"
He asked, out of habit.
He wasn't expecting to hear a voice on the
other line.
But then, he did.
Or rather, he heard the approximation of a
human voice, created by a swarm of anomalous
spiders.
It sounded a bit like a human voice sped up,
high-pitched and squeaky, speaking some sort
of gibberish.
Realizing that this was his moment to escape,
D-11424 placed the phone back in place, and
promptly left the testing chamber.
The spiders remained in the shape of the rotary
phone and the table for the next two hours,
at which point they disassembled and returned
to their home on SCP-3247.
After his surprisingly creative work in this
first test, it was decided that D-11424 would
be the designated test subject for all future
testing with SCP-3247, provided that additional
complications did not arise.
Though he wasn't especially fond of spiders,
D-11424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment, not that he had much choice in
the matter.
Still, it was definitely a better deal than
getting fed to SCP-682, and it was a nice
excuse to use his improv skills again after
a long retirement.
During the second test, D-11424 knew what
to expect from SCP-3247.
For this test, he was told to pantomime playing
tug of war with an invisible opponent and
an invisible rope.
Now that he knew his improvisational scene
partner would be a colony of spiders, he was
able to enter the testing chamber with confidence.
Once inside, he began to pantomime, pulling
on a rope, having that rope tugged away from
him by a strong opponent, and struggling to
pull back.
The spiders reacted right away, arranging
themselves into the shapes of a long rope,
one side of which was in D-11424's hands,
as well as a large, humanoid, vaguely masculine
shape that was holding the other side of the
rope.
The spiders gave the rope a sharp tug, causing
D-11424 to lose his balance and fall over,
the rope slipping out of his grasp.
Aside from some injury to his pride, he was
otherwise unharmed.
During Test 3, D-11424 was instructed to enter
the testing chamber and close his fist, while
extending the thumb and index finger in the
gesture colloquially known as "finger guns."
Sure enough, as soon as he assumed this position,
the spiders assembled into the shape of a
handgun.
D-11424 was then instructed to pick up the
spider gun and squeeze the place where the
trigger would be if it were a real gun and
not, you know, spiders.
A loud cracking sound was heard when the D-Class
squeezed, as a spider shot out of the barrel
of the gun at high speed before smacking into
the nearby wall, leaving a small hole in the
surface.
D-11424 fired several more times, each shot
firing an individual spider at a pace that
attending researchers described as "faster
than a speeding bullet."
After firing six rounds of spiders at the
wall, D-11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground.
During test 76, D-11424 was ordered to hold
his hands together and wiggle four fingers
on each hand, effectively pantomiming a spider.
The research team was curious to see what
the spiders would do when presented with a
shape that matched their usual, unassembled
form.
SCP-3247, who generally did not react much
to the experiments on its spiders, began shaking
its head in mild disappointment as approximately
six hundred and forty spiders emerged from
its body, dividing themselves into groups
of eight.
Each group of eight spiders then joined forces
to form one larger spider, leaving eight spiders.
These eight then split into pairs, who joined
together into one larger spider, and so on
and so forth until there was one single giant
spider made from the hundreds of smaller spiders.
At this point, D-11424 followed his heart,
jumping onto the mega-spider's back and riding
it like a bull at the rodeo, as the spider
bucked and ran back and forth across the room.
According to official transcripts, D-11424
yelled "yee-haw!"
throughout this part of the test, until the
head researcher ordered him to climb down
from the spider and exit the room.
He was reprimanded for his behavior, and warned
that, if he acted without approval again,
he would be taken off of the project and reassigned
to a much less enjoyable position as one of
the designated eyes on SCP-173.
D-11424 immediately agreed to comply with
future instructions.
During Test 133, D-11424 was sent into the
testing chamber and told to shadowbox.
He danced back and forth across the cell,
doing his best Sylvester Stallone impression
and throwing punches in the general direction
of the spiders.
In response, approximately 3000 spiders poured
out of SCP-3247, assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer, and began to attack D-11424.
The mass of spiders conducted itself at the
level of a professional boxer, dodging D-11424's
hits before coming back at him with a jab,
cross, lead uppercut, and rear uppercut before
he could defend himself.
D-11424 fell to the ground, unconscious, and
guards were forced to interrupt the test in
order to remove him from the room and take
him to the infirmary for medical treatment.
After taking some time to recuperate, D-11424
returned to testing with SCP-3247-A. He was
instructed to mime steering a wheel, such
as that of a car.
Immediately, a number of spiders previously
unseen during testing emerged from SCP-3247,
arranging themselves into the shape of a sedan.
D-11424 was then commanded to climb inside
of the spider car and see if he could start
it.
He refused, insisting "I'm not getting in
a spider car, are you nuts?!"
When pressed by Control to comply with orders,
he made a rude hand gesture.
The spiders began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed gesture,
prompting Control to stop the test early to
spare the researchers' sensibilities.
With strict guidelines to avoid inappropriate
or violent gestures, D-11424 was sent back
into the testing chamber with instructions
to try out a variety of animal-inspired gestures
in rapid succession.
He formed one hand into a fist, and made a
peace sign with the other hand, putting them
together to make a snail.
As he made his hand snail crawl through the
air, the spiders crawled onto the floor and
assembled into the shape of a snail in front
of D-11424.
Though the spiders moved quickly, at their
usual scuttling pace, once they formed into
the snail, they slowed to a gradual creep.
D-11424 noted a shiny, slimy trail left behind
on the floor as the spider-snail moved.
He was asked to consider touching it, but
refused, simply saying, "ew, no."
Next, he took his hands and formed the shape
of a wolf's head, howling at the moon.
The research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head, or the
animal's entire body.
They got their answer as the spiders swarmed
and shifted, forming the shape of a full-sized
grey wolf.
The wolf padded back and forth across the
room, before sitting down, lifting its head,
and emitting an audible howl that sounded
almost indistinguishable from the real thing.
Next, D-11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other, fluttering his hands like a pair of
wings.
The spiders separated into smaller groups
and came together to form butterflies similar
in size to a monarch.
These spider butterflies began to flap their
wings, and, much to D-11424's surprise, they
took flight and swirled through the air around
him.
The D-Class was so moved by the beautiful
sight that he shed a single tear, which he
promptly wiped away out of embarrassment.
Control then prompted him to try the next
animal gesture.
D-11424 used his hands to form the shape of
a rabbit.
Several of the spiders crawled away, returning
to SCP-3247, and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit.
The spider-rabbit hopped realistically around
the room, twitching its ears and tail.
At this point, D-11424 was instructed to offer
the spider rabbit a carrot.
He produced a carrot from his pocket, holding
it out in front of him.
The spider-rabbit hopped over to him, and,
one crunch at a time, began to eat the carrot
until none remained.
D-11424 appeared shaken up, and asked to leave
the testing chamber.
As he had followed all of his instructions,
this request was granted.
When he exited the chamber, all he would say
was "Where the hell did the carrot go?
It doesn't have a stomach...it doesn't have
a mouth...where'd it go?"
SCP-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber located
in the arachnid wing of Area-12.
It does not appear to require food or rest,
but it has been provided with a television
and a collection of silent films for morale
purposes.
Instances of SCP-3247-A are fed via a fully
automated system that dispenses twenty grams
of live crickets every week.
Should a containment breach occur, staff have
been instructed to find a way to make escaped
spiders take on a shape that renders them
motionless, then simply pick the spider cluster
up and place it back inside of the cell.
It is unlikely that the Foundation will ever
get an explanation for where the intangible
mime, and his merry band of spider performers,
originated from.
But one thing is clear, they won't be performing
in public again any time soon.
Now check out “SCP-058 - Heart of Darkness”
and “SCP-2427 - A Thing Full of Stuff”!